are you good enough for me and clap that
was the most delicate clap oh yeah it's
happening this is great paper stock by
the way where'd you get this I buy by
accident hi my name is work tell me if
you do not known I know your life is
different now today we have a very
exciting episode I mean it's very
obvious that what we're about to do here
we're about to cook run to cook
something very delicious very festive
and I don't know if it's gonna work
basically Diane my assistant she's off
camera over here you had a really great
idea to make donuts that look like
snowflakes we have this deep fryer
that's been sitting in the office since
our really fond corndog days I mean the
attempt is to make a doughnut that looks
like a snowflake so Diane basically
researched two different doughnut
recipes that she's sort of combined
together
Diane has some appropriate titles
holidays Donuts ho-ho Deez Nuts crusted
snow bakes snowballs is what I've
contributed
well here's your ingredients that you'll
need shortening crescent rolls has a
cinnamon roll
powdered sugar vanilla extract almond
milk
food color heat shortening until
temperature reaches 375 we just put the
shortening that serves as the oil that
we fry this in does this tub of butter
oh no that's where you put the donuts
won't it all melt enjoy I'm a
professional the best a goddess this is
a lot of smoke do we have a smoke alarm
in here this seems so wrong it's right
let's see it's melt and you see it right
but I don't know if we're gonna have
enough that that coats the hole all the
donuts this is the third one might be
our corn dog experiment all over again
I also definitely don't have enough oil
at all yeah this is enough I don't think
oh hey let this all sit meanwhile let's
pop open our crescent rolls and shape
our Deez Nuts ha
Happy New Year oh there she goes
oh that a rough night but now we shape
these into Donuts this is for the
shaping ban because these are all
perforated and pre-cut because we're
supposed to be crescent rolls we got to
kind of pinch them all together
I didn't I wash my hands I did wash my
hands but all of us there's some corner
of the internet that fetishizes this
moment right now
here we go okay one job you had one job
you had one job today and had these
adorable holiday what is this shirt this
oh so we'll just cut a quick snowflake I
am just audibly guessed
picture of health what festive is oh and
then we'll do just a snowball specimen
let's do a cinnamon one just so we have
some variation oh ok so the idea is to
just mash these up is this ASMR deal
with it it's got a million subscribers
from that very second moment hey girl
good morning so we put all of our donuts
in two at a time and they cook for one
minute on each side on each side let's
do our big uns first and we dip one in
we have a timer this is beautiful
that seems Guyana is literally standing
like this okay now we put them on the
drying rack then what we're going to do
is we're gonna cook all these donuts and
we're gonna make some icing to put on
top of them oh my god these cinnamon
ones are gonna be [ __ ] awesome my
heart just got tired Dan's gonna tend to
the doughnuts while I mix some icing
okay so we're just going to mix a bunch
of ingredients in three bowls we need a
cup of powdered sugar in each ball
bam-bam-bam have a teaspoon of salt in
there buddy
oh okay and have a teaspoon of vanilla
extract there she is
half a cup of almond milk and then we
put some food coloring in each one to
make them festive his kid take our spoon
and mix up this glaze it's gonna be
pretty runny so a little chunky yeah
good more powdered sugar oh now there
she is this one's Blasi we've run out of
powdered sugar to get the other ones too
lazy
we're just going to add some food color
let's see we got here blue yellow and
red how do you make green know as whose
red don't come for me oh ho that's amore
cuz Hannah Hart's here she's here the
Christmas purple let's see if we can
make green yellow and blue read me this
is Hanukkah and as per Diane's a recipe
blaze mix all glazed ingredients into a
bowl until smooth either drip or
decorate who cares it all goes down the
same garbage mouth tunnel
as as as those colors don't seem to have
mattered because it's dissolving
directly into the dough and remaining
the same color we did it
oh but some powder on top wow you are
living your Great British Bake Off
dreams right now
time's up hands up we did it we made
some delish well we'll find out the
delicious but we made some donuts we
made some snowballs solid yzma alla DS
look hope there's not whisking side now
it's the best time in this whole video
is that we get to taste these and you
wanna come Tacy's Fanta would you like
to come taste of holidays nuts
cheers Cheers Charlie wrong time [ __ ]
shot they're all wrong still eating
these nuts talk about raw doggin oh god
the thing we truly know then it's like
this video thumbs up just click this
button here subscribe my youtube channel
and try this at home for yourself see if
you did something it doesn't get your
family salmonella bad well hi friends
grace Helbig here you might remember me
from such videos as the one you just
finished watching well the holidays are
upon us and I thought I would gift you
with some cool content that you should
check out a lot of you know that I did a
series with 84 there hello labs program
called writing with grace and it was
amazing but I wasn't the only one in
hello labs there's nine other wonderful
creators in the program and I wanted to
tell you about a series that just
launched its Collins key he's an amazing
youtuber incredible magician he has
opened for Demi Lovato on tour because
that's how good of a magician he is he's
a series called a disappearing girl
where he has to try and find this
mystery girl that shows up at an AT&T
hello lab Meetup I'll put a link to that
right in the description box below it's
so great I think you guys would really
enjoy it so I just wanted to spread the
word it kiss hello loves em should be
editing right now
now we have bigger fish to fry
get out of my video